we are back with another episode of the
wine down and today we're joined by the
lovely Christina Elmore who plays in
dolet and we'll be discussing Loki
thankful what do you think and Ola
doesn't initially invite Lawrence to
Thanksgiving I think that's such a
complicated question but I do think
ultimately she's being honest when she
says to him I didn't want to feel
pressured and I didn't want you to feel
pressure I think that we haven't really
gotten to the point yet when we're
talking about like meeting families or
meeting even close friends and I just
don't feel like we're there yet right
wait was condolence sought process did
he sort of invite himself and not canola
fields put-upon yeah what's her feelings
about exposing herself to I think when I
just went with the Kristina perspective
which is that like I would be really
mortified to say hey my very special
friends giving with all my very best
friends and then him be like no I'm just
gonna go get this Hennessy Turkey yeah
and so I think he never brings it up I
never bring it up because I think we're
both kind of afraid of like being
vulnerable in that way do you guys feel
like Lawrence is more into the
relationship than condole is I'm
inclined to say no I feel like him
saying oh I didn't know you wanted a
family and oh I'm ready for this next
step is more because he's ready for next
steps in his life rather than like is he
actually ready for next step with canola
at his moment that's fair
so do you think that when she saw
Lawrence and ISA at the coffee shop yeah
they're your spot you thought i condole
ileft that like feeling secure in her
relationship or do you feel like she
left like oh there there might be
something I have to worry about here I
think it was like one of the first like
chinks in the armor like it was like oh
you thought Lawrence still have jokes
that are funny and
Oh yo and look there's wit and stuff
going back and forth yes do you guys
think it's possible to be friends with
your ex and not have any feelings for
them it's possible it's not probable I
mean I think it's possible I think it's
possible I just don't see the need I
don't know that's like you can have no
feelings for them anymore for sure I
think that's totally possible but it's
the I don't want to be with you in that
way yeah and I don't have any feelings
for you why do we want to be friends I'm
cool
yeah we don't have conversations like if
I saw you in the street it wouldn't be
like die I don't know I just I don't
want to see you do better to me you
would what to see you out there well I
got better do I guess I would never
acknowledge no no I'm a legit but he's
too tall he's two teeth to chest right
on hey thank you again for joining us
see you next time
you